[Music]
all right we are back all right as you
know number one bestseller building a
nonanxious life hit the market it's been
out and it's selling like crazy it's
done so good 100% of that goes to you
guys thank you so so much for that um we
recorded a series that is now taken off
on YouTube and um on this podcast and so
we want to um bring the third
installment the six daily choices
today's daily choice is one that you've
heard me talk about if you pre-ordered
the book and you got the talk it's on
this idea of choosing freedom in a world
that has taken every single Choice from
us every single thought from us even the
great Robert sapowsky the doctor the
professor Dr Robert sapowsky the
professor out of Stanford who has
written extensively on do we even have
free will does that even exist
in a world where every single thought
every single action is so carefully
thought
through the great Michael Easter wrote a
new book called scarcity brain where he
talks about how
businesses have just straight hacked our
minds and we wake up and we are anxious
and we are cooked and we are fried and
the bank is telling us what we're going
to do tomorrow and our phones are
telling us to look look look look look
look and the processed foods and our
Pantry telling us to eat eat eat eat eat
and the news is telling us who to be mad
at and who to be enraged at and our boss
is screaming at
us this idea of choosing freedom is so
countercultural yet it's so
powerful in our fight to live a
non-anxious
life and so check out this um vignette
if you will I've always wanted to say
vignette actually I've never wanted to
say vignette until just now but this
little vignette um if you're watching on
on YouTube check it out if you're
listening to it on podcast you can
listen to it here and I also suggest go
to John delone do or go to youtube/
jalone not john.com YouTube J delone to
watch this um was beautifully shot by
Wes and his
team this is the third choice for
building a non-anxious life choosing
Freedom check it
out it's the moment your body realizes
that you are not in control and what
comes next in your life it will sound
the anxi alarms you will be anxious it
has to sound the anxiety alarms cuz
you're not okay this is why you must
choose Freedom if you really want to
build a non-anxious
[Music]
life so here I am the guy that travels
the country telling people about anxiety
and how to live non-anxious lives right
start writing a book and then I start
speaking on stages and then I launch a
little podcast that takes off and then
all of a sudden I started saying yes to
everything even things I didn't want to
do I started telling my kids hold on I
started telling my wife let's look at
next weekend let's look at the weekend
after that I stopped calling my friends
back when they were taxed and suddenly I
found myself once again chasing titles
and accolades and bank accounts and my
body started slowly sounding the alarms
and it was my wife who one morning came
downstairs and then she said something
that I didn't have a psychology for she
said John we have
enough and that rocked me
[Music]
and there's a part of your brain that
it's specific job is to look at problems
and find Solutions look into the future
and say is this a good deal and there's
also a part of your brain designed to
keep you safe you're telling me if we
get fired from our job they're going to
take our cars that we don't own but we
live in a culture that just says why
would you pay cash for a car that's so
dumb you know how nice of a car you can
get and how low you can get that payment
and so Financial freedom is I will never
borrow money for a depreciating asset
solving for Freedom when it comes to
money means not owing anybody
anything our bodies are designed for
scarcity for not enough and so we fill
our homes up with stuff and we're
scanning all the time and it's never
enough and we get more stuff and more
stuff and instead of our tribal Natures
instead of looking around saying we're
good now we have these little devices
and we're not competing with the Joneses
anymore we're competing with everyone on
planet Earth we can't fit all of our
stuff in our 2000 3,000 4,000 ft homes
so we have to rent other air conditioned
places to put our stuff into but we look
around and we're
suffocating under stuff under clutter
Freedom looks like asking yourself do I
have this shelf of books because I'm
going to read them or do I have this
shelf of books
because I need to announce to the world
whoever comes into my home look how
smart I am look at what I read one time
and if you're looking for inanimate
objects to give you your identity you're
not free what are we doing we're
drowning and
[Music]
clutter so I love time and by love time
I mean I love how much I hate time cuz
it just never stops moving and so what
do I do I get a new app I get a new
program I read another book and another
book and another book and I get a new
day planner and most of us live
calendars that are so packed that we
can't breathe and we get mad that the
clock keeps spinning and there's never
enough time and we always want to do
this and this and this and this and we
Sprint from one thing to the next thing
to the next thing and most of us aren't
struggling with alcohol or other
addictions that we can point fingers at
most of us are addicted to busy we're
asking our bodies to do something it
wasn't designed to do which is to go go
go go go and so choosing Freedom when it
comes to time is about taking your
calendar and putting it on your desk and
taking your arm and swiping it across
and clearing the whole thing then you
ask yourself this one question who do we
want to be what do we want it to feel
like when we walk into our front door
most people say we want it to be warm we
want there to be laughter we want there
to be a place where we drop our
shoulders and so choosing Freedom with
time means saying
no and that soccer coach doesn't get to
tell you what you do with your weekends
unless you let them and your kids are
great kids and what they really want is
you not another activity so what I'm
asking you to do what I'm asking myself
to do is give ourselves space to be
bored to reflect to think to create to
examine to sit on the stool in between
rounds so that you can get back in the
ring and fight like mad but you have to
create
[Music]
space boundaries get to be a mess in our
current culture because with social
media with our relationships with our
parents and our in-laws that are just
never ending we don't know where we stop
and where the world begins we are IM
mesed in everybody and everything as of
this recording I have about half a
million friends on Facebook I have about
half a million friends on Instagram and
they write me about what I should be
saying and what I should have said
differently and how dare I and thank
goodness that you're saying whatever it
is you're saying my body is not designed
to take input from a million people I've
never met my body's designed to have a
small Core group of people and we all
agree that this is how we're going to do
life how many of us still let our inlaws
tell us what we're doing for Christmas
how many of us let our boss determine
our selfworth how many of us say yes to
every invitation because the world
revolves around us and without us the
whole world falls down a boundary is a
reverse Golden Rule a boundary is saying
I love others enough and I love myself
enough that I'm going to do what I need
to do to stay whole and well so that I
can go out and serve so I can go out and
love so I can be fully able to show up
when other people are speaking into your
life telling you what you're going to do
and when you're going to do it and how
you're going to do it your body will
sound the alarms because it recognizes
you're in the back seat of your own life
somebody else is driving and so if you
want to live a life free from anxiety
you have to choose
boundaries
the journey starts with identity and
when you begin to identify who you want
to be I want to be a dad who laughs I
want to be a wife who's not stressed out
in running all the time because I'm
someone who chooses Freedom I'm going to
pay off all my debts because I'm someone
who chooses Freedom I'm getting rid of
all the Clutter I'm putting margin in my
calendar I'm making a short short list
of who gets to speak into my life
choosing freedom is about agency it's
about autonomy it's about you being in
the driver seat of your own life choose
freedom and build a non-anxious
[Music]
life